>> Tucker: PHILADELPHIA D.A.
LARRY KRASNER MADE IT CLEAR
TOP PRIORITY IS PROTECTING
THE CITY'S CRIMINALS RATHER
THAN LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN.
THAT'S BAD ENOUGH IN THE
ABSTRACT.
IT'S EASY TO FORGET THAT
THIS POLICY HAS REAL
VICTIMS.
IT HAS DESTROYED THE LIVES
OF REAL PEOPLE.
MICHAEL WHITE STABBED SEAN
SCALLINGER TO DEATH AFTER
BRAGGING ONLINE HE WAS ABOUT
TO CUT SOMEONE.
NO DISPUTE HE DID IT.
KRASNER WOULD NOT CHARGE HIM
WITH HOMICIDE.
THE CASE WAS WEAKENED BY
THAT SO BADLY THAT WHITE IN
THE END WOUND UP WITH JUST
PROBATION.
NOW, LAST WEEK
PHILADELPHIA'S HILL COLLEGE
INVITED KRASNER AND WHITE TO
ITS, QUOTE, TRANSFORMING
JUSTICE CONFERENCE.
WHITE WAS USED AN AMPLE
EXAMPLE.
A STANDOUT EXAMPLE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
LINDA IS THE MOTHER OF THE
MURDERED MAN SEAN SCHOOL
JERRY.
SHE
RECENTLY SPOKE TO US ABOUT
IT.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY ABOUT
THIS AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT MUST BE LIKE FOR YOU
TO SEAT MAN WHO MURDERED
YOUR SON HELD UP AS A HERO.
WHAT IS IT LIKE?
-- OUTRAGE JUST.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FORM IT IS APPALLING
TO ME THAT THEY WOULD DO
SUCH A THING.
OBVIOUSLY NOT
UNDERSTANDABLE.
WENT TO A CONFERENCE ON
FRIDAY FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
LARRY KRASNER WAS SPEAKING.
MY INTENTION WAS TO SEE WHAT
LARRY HAD TO SAY HAVE AN
OPEN MIND ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
TO MY SURPRISE WHEN I GOT
THERE, MICHAEL WHITE, MY
SON'S KILLER WAS ON THE
AGENDA TO SPEAK ON A PANEL
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: IT'S HARD TO
UNDERSTAND -- IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
ALSO CONFUSING.
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF THIS?
WHY WOULD COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT CERTAIN
THAT THE COLLEGE WAS
ACTUALLY AWARE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
AT LEAST WHAT THEY PRESENTED
TO ME IS THAT THEY WERE NOT
AWARE THAT MICHAEL WHITE WAS
WHO HE WAS AND THAT HE WAS
PUT ON THIS PANEL.
HE DID NOT END UP ACTUALLY
SPEAKING BECAUSE AT THE 11TH
HOUR THEY DECIDED TO CHANGE
THAT AGENDA UP AND PUT TWO
GENTLEMEN WHO HAD BEEN IN
PRISON FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND HAD APPARENTLY NOT
COMMITTED THE MURDERS THAT
THEY WERE ACCUSED OF, MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO.
OBVIOUSLY, TWO PEOPLE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WOULD WARRANT
SPEAKING ON A PANEL LIKE
THAT, RATHER THAN PUTTING
SOMEONE LIKE MICHAEL WHITE
UP TO MAKE A MOCKERY OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THAT
WOULD BE GOING ON.
I COMPLETELY CAN'T
UNDERSTAND IT EXCEPT A
POLITICAL AGENDA BY LARRY
KRASNER AND THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY TIARA BRADFORD
GRAY.
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS YOUR
SECOND TIME ON OUR SHOW AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
BACK.
>> YES.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: FOR THE VIEWERS
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE BACK
STORY.
THIS MURDER TOOK PLACE IN
PUBLIC.
THE MAN WHO STABBED YOUR SON
TO DEATH.
AND THEY HAD NEVER MET
BEFORE.
WHO STABBED HIM TO DEATH.
LATER WROTE A RAP SONG ABOUT
IT.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT HE
DID IT.
SO, GIVEN THAT WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY TO LARRY KRASNER WHO
IS BRAGGING ABOUT GETTING,
IN EFFECT, GETTING THIS GUY
OFF FOR YOUR SON'S MURDER?
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM.
>> I WOULD SAY YOU ARE AN
EVIL AND VERY SICK MAN.
I MEAN, IT LITERALLY RISES
TO THAT LEVEL.
THIS IS NOT JUST A
DISAGREEMENT AROUND
PROSECUTOR'S STRATEGY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I THINK I HAD MENTIONED TO
YOU BEFORE, I BELIEVE THAT
HE OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
THERE IS ZERO QUESTION THAT
MICHAEL PLUNGED A KNIFE INTO
MY SON'S BACK WITH
EYEWITNESSES SURROUNDING HIM
ON A LOVELY EVENING IN JULY
NONE.
ZERO.
SO, THIS WAS THEATER AT ITS
BEST.
THIS WAS COMPLETELY
ORCHESTRATED BY LARRY
KRASNER, RIGHT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE
ASTOUNDING.
I MEAN THIS PANEL DISCUSSION
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO PUT
THIS PERSON ON, IF I CAN
EVEN CALL HIM A PERSON, IS
HE A MURDERER IS, AGAIN, I
KEEP USING THE WORD
OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE IT IS SO
BEYOND MY UNDERSTANDING OF
ANYTHING THAT MAKES ANY
GOOD, COMMON LOGICAL SENSE.
>> SO THEY CAN STAB YOUR SON
TO DEATH IN THE MIDDLE OF
WRITTEN HOUSE SQUARE AND IN
EFFECT MOCK HIM AND YOU IN
PUBLIC THAT'S WHAT LARRY
KRASNER IS DOING.
I HOPE YOU GET GLUIVE THIS
CASE.
I HOPE YOU WILL COME BACK